In the 1960s, at the height of the space race,...
...space food was either compressed into utilitarian packages...
...or pureed into a tube.
NASA did this in part to reduce the dangers free-floating crumbs could pose,...
...like wreaking havoc on the space capsule's instruments.
During the Gemini 3 mission, astronaut John Young...
...didn't quite get the memo...
...when he snuck a contraband corned beef sandwich into space.
Sure, the sandwich could have caused a life-threatening accident,...
...but, hey, wouldn't you wanna know how a sandwich tasted in space?
Young was reprimanded for his actions, but luckily for him,...
...the incident didn't derail his career.
He later was part of the Apollo 16 mission and walked on the moon.
But that time, he made sure to leave his packed lunch at home.
Tranquility Base here.
The Eagle has landed.